in your work you you quote Nietzsche
quite a bit his a line "he who has a why
to live for can bear almost any how". What do you think he meant by that?
What I think that..?
What you think he meant by that? The same as
I'm intended to convey to my readers and
students: that the vision of a meaning
ahead of someone, a meaning in wait for
someone to be fulfilled by someone, that
this contributes most than anything else
under equal other circumstances for
survival. Meaning is the most important
thing in our lives? Certainly because a
what I call a "will to meaning" - the wish
to find and to fulfill meaning is the
basic motivation in human beings.
This certainly runs counter to much of
the determinist notions that are being
bandied around these days that
man is a machine man is a computer man
is a product of instincts. Man is
something like a rat in experiments
psychological experiments. Of course you
are right but not only against the
so called deterministic concepts of man but
also regarding the motivational theories
of certain psychotherapeutic systems.
Let's talk for a minute about
logotherapy
which arose out of this notion of a
search for meaning. Logotherapy, as one
among other types of psychotherapy, is
we may say a "meaning centered" psychotherapy
in as much particularly as logotherapy
sees a human being not predominantly
determined, not to say dominated by the
will to pleasure as you were mentioning, nor
by the will to power along the lines of
Adlerian teachings, but basically
fundamentally by a will to meaning.
That is to say the desire, the impulse to
find to discover in life or better to
say in each life situation, concrete life
situation confronting someone, the desire
to find a meaning therein and
to go on to fulfill it. I was very
intrigued one of the most surprising
things I've read recently was that you
said that when you talk to European
students only 40 percent said they had
suffered this sort of inner void and yet
eighty-one percent of American students
experience the same thing.
We think of it just the opposite,
we think of the Europeans as being
buried under this existential dread and
sense of purposelessness and Americans
is being optimistic and upbeat.
However it might be, whether the ones or
the others are suffering more
or less respectively from this
existential vacuum, the ones who seem to
suffer less should not look at the
others with contempt but look at the
others with compassion and look for
anything possible to help the others. Now
this void manifests itself as in apathy
in boredom, lack of initiative,
lack of interest - interest in the world
or initiative in changing something
within the world for the better. This
frustration is a a proof of the
existence of a will to meaning. Unless we
were imbued by a will to meaning by the
wish to find meaning and discuss
discover and fulfill meaning in life
we never
would be able to experience an inner
void so this is in a way also something
positive.
Now you've listed three types of values
creative values, experiential values and
attitudinal variants. You may find a
meaning the "average" man, the man on the
street or the woman on the street may
find a meaning day by day in doing a
deed in creating a work and - that's the
creative - creative and in experiencing
something. The beauty. The truth as a
researcher, or the good in dealing with
people as a teacher or whatsoever. There's an
extraordinary moment in "man's search for
meaning" when you talk about being in one
of the one of the Nazi camps and all of
you going out to look at a sunset. Is
that experiential? Exactly this is a paradigm of
experiential values, of finding a meaning
in experiencing without doing anything
without achieving or accomplishing
anything but just in giving oneself the
immediate experience of something say
beautiful going on in the world. This is
the second avenue but there is also
another aspect of experiential
values. Excuse me, not only experiencing
something but also experiencing someone.
More than that, experiencing
another human being in his
or her very uniqueness and it is the
main attribute of a human being that he
is a person in contrast to any animal he
is a person a person is always something
absolutely unique irreparable in the
evolution of the cosmos as is we are
incomparable with any other human being
and this uniqueness can be got hold of
solely by a loving person, Because he not
only sees the essence but also the
potentials in the beloved person
thereby as I put it before promoting him
alleviating it to reach out to attain
this potential and to fulfill and
thereby actualize also himself but not
by preaching self-actualization. It's
nonsense
self-actualization can only fall into
your lap automatically once that you
have fulfilled a concrete meaning, done
the best of a situation. Then you actualize
yourself as a by-product. Let's talk
about the third set of values which is
the attitudinal, the idea of choosing how
to respond to suffering.
Choosing the attitude - yes. If there is no
possibility in a given situation to
fulfill the meaning of a situation by
giving oneself to the experience of
beauty and so forth. Nor if you have lost the
capability to do your job to do your
work even then there is an ultimate
possibility to find and
fulfill meaning - not only the ultimate it
is even the potential to fulfill the
deepest meaning, to attain the highest values:
by your approach to the given situation, a tragic
or trist situation confronting you. You said
that in part of the initial shock of
being put in a death camp was there was
was ultimately an acceptance that we
knew we had nothing to lose
except our ridiculously naked lives is
that the situation that they're in? - In
a way - Is this when you
make the choice of how you go into..
your last value choices how to react to
the situation? You stand there, you stood
there naked with nothing you could have
had but all the more what counted and
the mattered was what
you were - "being" rather than "having",
possessing anything. So what
counted was what you make out of this
situation, what attitude you adopt
in the given situation and there is a
multitude a wealth of possible attitudes
to how to approach it. So we have to
decide. The ultimate I would take it
attitudinal value challenge that we all share
is how we're going to face death. How do
you prepare people for that? How do you
prepare yourself for that?
I couldn't prepare anyone else unless I would have prepared myself
because if you are a psychiatrist
your patients feel exactly whether or
not you are really convinced of what you
are teaching and telling them. Now I'm
convinced that in contrast to the usual
aspect or be it sound aspect to life and
more specifically to the
past, to life's transitoriness and this
includes that we approach, each of us are
approaching death, in contrast to that I
maintain that in the past nothing is
lost but right on the contrary
everything is stored forever.
It is not annihilated by transitoriness
but on the contrary it has been, it is
becoming preserved forever. Something you
have done can never be undone. Something
you have experienced something you have
even experienced in a negative sense
going through suffering and if for
instance you suffered, gone through this
suffering
honestly courageously and with dignity
who in the world, what what in the world
can deny it,
can annihilate this? What you have done
has been done forever
in both ways in a negative as in a
positive way, it cannot be
undone. And the past is a storehouse of
what you have done what you have
experienced what you have gone through
and what you have done out of all the
negative and tragic aspects as even
encountered within your life. I want to
thank you for being on the show
and I want to thank you at home for
watching.